you don't know why you're here you're
about to find out
you do know I let you kidnap me right no
would have taken you I doubt it
unless you have a kryptonite arrow in
that quiver hmm anyway so what's with
all the mysterious mystery you tell her
oh wait a sec is this that bike club
thing oh oh I've heard so much about
this I'm so excited we thought the
abduction was cool you're really gonna
like the upgrade we thought we needed to
up the ante for someone of your
abilities which is awesome is this where
you train it's more of a team up
training facility with teen tech pulling
the strings
a superhero Fight Club 2.0 more like
Fight Club 9.0 last one was about as
legit as Commodore 64 Oh
[Music]
hey youtubers is Charlie it's a new
Fight Club trailer we also learned about
the four night crossover so let's break
it down they also like CW also made it
easier for you to watch the shows after
they air so I'll explain at the end of
this - so if you guys don't remember it
from last year they did like a superhero
Fight Club
it was like a big promo it was like a
small episode or anything it was really
just intended to promote the big three
night crossover so you had a bunch of
villains like Merlyn you had the
reverse-flash then you had all the
superheroes in their costume fighting
Thunderdome style like in this cage
match so this is just like the next step
up from that introducing Supergirl to
the full yeah the funny introduction
where Oliver just doesn't quite
understand that Supergirl is just so
crazy powerful that he's gonna have to
find himself some kryptonite arrows I
will be interested to see if he
eventually gets a kryptonite ring like
Batman has a kryptonite ring you know
just like a measure of last resort in
case something goes wrong with Supergirl
or Superman now that we have Kryptonians
in this universe but they turned it into
more of a Danger Room thing and Gorilla
Grodd ends up being like their big
team-up boss so of course there's going
to be a big gorilla city episode this
year on the flash I don't know if it's
going to have anything to do with the
four night crossover or if it's going to
be its own thing there's supposed to be
like a two part gorilla City episode but
that's just a rumor right now all we
know is that Gorilla Grodd is going to
be a big thing but the rest of this is
just them having fun with the idea of
the big team-up Cisco and Felicity work
in the control room
dig eating the big belly burger is just
like a funny callback to the first time
he met the flash during the flash season
1 arrow season 3 where they did like the
Captain Boomerang crossover and he
spills all of his fries when Barry comes
running up just like oh my god there's a
metahuman so think about how he's going
to his pants when he sees Martian
Manhunter in Supergirl like he hasn't
met aliens yet in aliens or like the
dominators are the big part of the
four-night crossover they're invading
Earth that's the MacGuffin of the
crossover so we'll talk a little bit
more about that when they release more
information but they just teased that
the dominators are the reason that
everybody teams up so it's going to be a
lot of fun like the look on super girls
so she's just like so excited to play
it's just like the perfect tee up for
how crazy it's going to get this season
so let me know like what do you guys
most excited for in this big four night
crossover this year if you were
wondering yeah I mean it really does
help to watch all four shows but I'll be
doing videos for everything so if you
missed up don't worry you could watch my
videos I'll explain the Easter eggs
where everything is crossing over what
the hell's going on week to week so it's
going to be a lot of fun in arrow and
flash come back next week Supergirl and
legends of tomorrow the week after that
so those are still two weeks off but
flash and arrow dropped next week so get
hype it is going to be crazy the other
big point in the CW making this video is
to promote the way it's revamping its
digital presence so from like the top to
the bottom
things have changed they tried to make
it easier for you to actually watch the
episodes after they air so whatever
platform you're normally used to using
to watch the TV shows it should be
easier to find them online after they
air
so that's week to week as they air
through the year after the season is
over they also redid their deal with
Netflix so you can watch all four shows
on Netflix eight days after all the
finales they're in the spring but that's
going to be in June so like when the
flash season 3 has its finale for
example eight days after that all of
season three will be on Netflix so do
whatever you got to do to find the
show's week to week I will say like I
recommend do not watch them on your
phone there's so many different ways to
watch TV shows try to watch it in the
biggest shiniest format possible whether
or not you have a TV doesn't matter if
you have a computer try to watch the
episodes on desktop they look so much
better when you watch them on a big
screen
but no worries they've just done
everything they can to make sure that
people who do not own a TV can still
watch the episodes week to week so
there's going to be a couple more
trailers that I'll post in the next day
or so I think there's going to be new
flash footage that'll drop tomorrow but
I have a new flash video that I'm going
to make I'm finishing my arrow trailer
video so a whole bunch of DC stuff
dropping in the next
couple days there is a new round of the
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video it's gonna be just like
last year so they'll still be giveaways
week to week through the DC videos but
gorilla grodd gorilla City dominators
killer fraud like all the things that
you wish that they would do they are
totally doing this year on all the TV
shows it's gonna be crazy and I did find
out that YouTube is making even more
changes than I thought they were so if
there's like a problem viewing my videos
or there's some kind of bug that should
go away pretty soon but once everything
settles I'll try to explain what's
different but for the most part you guys
shouldn't see any differences in the way
you view my videos I did get a new
camera so like it looks a little bit
different on screen but for the most
part everything should still be the same
as it's been this whole year so if
YouTube is giving you big problems just
let me know in the comments that's
usually the best way to find out that
something's broken what you guys wait
for that to post you can click here for
my arrow hundredth episode video and you
can click here for my last big flash
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight